Pat Leonard is the Giants beat writer
columnist for the New York Daily News
and he joins us now how much drama
do we have what's the local reaction to
the first two weeks of the season with
the g-men Pat in Houston this weekend
full two and three again just like last
year when they swarmed oh and three
losing in Philadelphia not take Elliot
61 yards field goal the reaction is this
a lot of fans are getting deja I'll do a
little bit about what then Mac is
offense with Eli Manning under Center
wasn't able to do last year their yards
from scrimmage around the 250 mark in
week 2 with the lowest total since the
game that led McAdoo to bench Eli
Manning last year Thanksgiving night at
Washington with 170 yards so there's a
little bit of panic here a little bit of
a giant skill position players wanting
the ball in their hands or and just a
bad feeling after an optimistic start
where they overturn the front office and
a lot of the roster your most recent
article I believe you state the Giants
only have themselves to blame for
foolishly believing Eli Manning still
has it and now they'll pay the
consequences do you think that they
looked at this is a one that this was a
one-year or a year to year where if Eli
had it they had a chance to compete for
the Super Bowl or make the playoffs here
and that's what they were rolling the
dice on they believe that Eli could be
the quarterback for at least two final
years of his contract so that would go
through next season
you know what was interesting is that a
lot of people thought that they would
retool this roster and look towards the
long-term future especially with the
quarterback class he was looking at in
April but what the day of gentlemen did
it was very clear when he traded for
Howard Ogletree the linebacker in his
late 20s from the Los Angeles Rams with
a big contract coming with him it was
very clear that gentlemen had a
different thing in mind it was we didn't
do right by Eli Manning last year we
need to give him better pieces around
him both on offense and on the defensive
side of the ball and the idea was let's
go and win one more Super Bowl of Eli
Manning let's give him the best chance
for one more run but not a wise decision
Stanwell his parent is at this point in
his career and how much depth you the
organization and the roster lacks at so
many key position with say Quan Barkley
the right choice at number two no he
wasn't and I he's a very special player
I mean the judge you know the giant
anything that has any lucky to happen
it's no fun to Barkley she's an
excellent player the guy didn't miss
evaluate his talent or how good he could
or will be in my opinion I think they
miss evaluated where the organization
was and even if you are going to take a
great player like Berkeley or position
players such as badly trouble or quite
invested in that top ten I thought
gentlemen are very badly and not taking
or making a phone call when they were on
the clock at number two he was very
proud of telling everybody and when
Pinker Mayfield went to the Browns at
one he basically told everyone in the
room don't take any calls we know over
picking he would have put the pick in
before in five minutes in if he was
allowed to buy NFL rule you could have
baited the Jets maybe to come up a
little bit more because you could talk
to teams like the Broncos or the bills I
think it still could have Mac and gotten
a quarterback and you had a lot of other
heats not to mention that he played a
lot of the players he has signed to fill
those needs can create he also have that
produced fruit so far for the Giants how
do you think this plays out this year I
was I was trying to be optimistic coming
in especially because I wanted L Beckham
jr. out here every day and he looked
excellent in the preseason and you can
tell he is healthy so week one obviously
11 touches he could have had over 200
yards of matting hit him I'm pessimistic
now because not only do I not have faith
in manic were the offensive line shaping
up quickly enough but the Giants
schedule just doesn't allow them any
breathing room until the second half of
the year you know they play a lot of
Super Bowl contenders right through here
they have New Orleans they have the
defending champion Eagles have to go on
the road Monday night at Atlanta so I do
think Pat shirbil
knows what he's doing I don't think his
scheme is responsible for all wrong so
far but he needs to get he need to
figure this out in a hurry
because the offensive line and the
quarterback are not letting his offense
get on the ground
the way that it did in Minnesota and the
Giants have the skill position players
so it's the line and the quarterback
that are holding that back in my opinion
he's fat Leonard the Giants beat writer
and columnist for The New York Daily
News joining us Dan Patrick show you
also have the Sam Darnell defect with
the Jets how much is that going to play
into you know what the Giants do or
don't do over the next five to ten years
in what the Jets do with Sam darn 'old
that's a great question and it really
it's it's hanging over their head from
day one and we know that Donald has
thrown some interceptions he's not going
to be perfect but Giants fans who say
well we wouldn't be any better with
Donald this year they're missing the
point
the idea is that Eli Manning if the
Giants are recognizing the realities
here they have an opportunity to build
around a quarterback like Donald not
only who's talented and you know
optimistic for the future
and also has almost salary cap he could
have built around this young quarterback
like the Rams like the Eagles like the
Jets now the Giants are about to go if
they're if they're not careful and it
looks like it may be too late they're
about to enter the state's annually of
signing a free agent quarterback who can
help them or having to go into the draft
and getting another one but will they
have a high enough pick like they did
this year to get that done every time
the Jets on preaching how much Donald is
doing and impressing people every time
one of his teammates says how much of a
leader he is and how precocious he is
that's another needle in the side of the
Giants and it's not just falling but the
fact that he's in this market makes it
all the more real for potentially hot
back the Giants air here and you know
they may have to look at a guy like Nick
Foles you know he doesn't opt in with
the school next year you know if he
becomes a free agent Pat sure and
they're coached him in Philadelphia
strimmers song Kyle's senior at
Vanderbilt not a projected first-round
pick but these are just the names that
you already have to start thinking about
and the Giants have been looking and
fortunate that Eli Manning has been so
consistent and been their starter all
these years but it's time to move on and
they should have moved on early and now
they're going to have to you know really
play the market
year in and year out is Eli Manning the
quarterback of this team by the end of
the year by the end of this year yes
because the Giants eliminated anyone
really who would have to take his place
by training Davis Webb no one's gonna be
clamoring for Alec caddy who has one
career started journeyman backup to
replace him Kyle Lillet is a good kid
but has to develop so he will be the
quarterback at the end of the year but I
don't think he will or should be going
into next year he's a 23 million dollar
cap it the Giants can sit on most of it
by releasing him before the middle of
the spring and you know they have talked
like they want him to be the quarterback
very really maybe I don't think can be
or should be for them to be competitive
and I think it would again slow down
their wrist build into whenever they
intend to contend in the future bad good
stuff thanks for joining us we
appreciate your time Pat Leonard Giants
beat writer Connell Miss New York Daily
News for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]